[Music]
one of the great experiences in
education is taking a at first difficult
complex classic texts like Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics in unlocking it
finding the wisdom the riches the depths
inside that work and then applying it to
your own life I'm Gregory Sam for the
president and founder of reason I oh and
I'm here to help you do that with
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics I'm very
excited to be able to announce that we
are now offering a two course sequence
in the reason I own Academy on
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics why two
courses well I provide the students with
so many of resources that i didn't want
to overload them in just one massive
course so we've split it up into books
one through five in the first course
book six through ten in the second
course we're also pricing them so that
you can purchase them separately or at a
reduced price in a bundle these courses
are entirely online which means that
they're available for you wherever you
go practically speaking you can take a
month to complete them you can take a
year to complete them you can work
through them multiple times you can
access the resources whenever and
wherever you find convenient what are
the resources that i developed and built
into this course to support your
learning as you work your way through
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics well
there's so many of them I have to
actually compile a list I provide the
learners with 94 short that is from ten
to 25-minute long videos each on some
major idea in the nick of mccain ethics
94 videos that's quite a few 38 lesson
pages each of which is sort of like a
blog entry 27 downloadable handouts 11
downloadable worksheets that you can
fill in you can print out as many of
them as you like there are 15 question
quizzes on each of the books to help you
test your understanding
there's discussion questions that you
can use to crop your own thinking
discussion forums where you can engage
me and your fellow students and in some
cases other resources as well so each
book gets its own section full of all of
these resources I'm going to give you a
little sneak peek at some of those right
here you can see me scrolling through
you can see the lesson pages the videos
other resources that I'm providing it's
quite a lot if you want to study this
difficult but incredibly rewarding and
massively influential work of virtue
ethics Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
with an expert guide like myself
somebody who has published on
Aristotle's who's been teaching him for
over 20 years then you want to check out
this course sequence it can by going to
the video description down below and
clicking on the link it will take you to
the page you'll be able to preview some
of the contents then you can decide
whether you want to purchase it or not
one last thing keep an eye on the reason
I owe page as well because we offer free
webinars and more intensive online
seminars on a variety of philosophical
authors sometimes it's Aristotle and you
can get some live interaction with me
through that if you sign up for the
course and you sign up for the webinars
or online seminars you're going to have
a very powerful learning experience
[Music]